pour la première fois sous la vème
république deux membres d'un même
gouvernement s'affronte dans une même
ville lors d'une élection municipale
c'est à biarritz que didier guillaume
ministre de l'agriculture et
jean-baptiste lemoyne secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères ont décidé de se
mesurer
aucun des deux n'est originaire de la
cité balnéaire de 25000 habitants
didier guillaume a fait toute sa
carrière politique dans la drôme et
jean-baptiste lemoyne dans l'yonne
mais le ministre de l'agriculture a pris
les devants sur son concurrent en
officialisant sa candidature sur place
samedi dernier je suis candidat après
une longue réflexion
après une mûre réflexion je ne viens pas
là par amour encore que l'amour de la
ville est important j'aime cette ville
depuis longtemps julien laparre raison
début décembre le bureau exécutif de la
république en marche a décidé de la
neutralité concernant l'investiture à
biarritz interrogé sur un éventuel
arbitrage d'emmanuel macron didier
guillaume votant pour il s'agit pas de
démissionner ça ces discussions qui ceux
qui seront prises avec le présent de la
république et le premier ministre
je ne demande pas au besoin d'arbitrés à
ma faveur de la jeune marianne au
président la république en marche a fait
le choix de la neutralité sur cette
ville
ce choix me va très bien en mars didier
guillaume défiera la liste modem du
maire sortant michel veunac l'actuel
édile s'étonne de la candidature du
ministre de l'agriculture
pour l'élu biarrot il s'agit tout
simplement d'un parachutage
c'est une candidature qui est le mot est
faible vraiment surprenante voilà un élu
de la drôme ministre de l'agriculture
qui ce parachute à biarritz qui jette
son dévolu sur cette ville qu'il ne
connaît pas qui ne le connais pas et
tout d'un coup son avenir politique est
là peut-être parce qu'il n'est nulle
part ailleurs c'est à venir
politique je suis modem avec les mots
voisin françois bayrou et le maire de
pau évidemment soutient ma candidature
bien évidemment j'ai des messages
d'encouragement du président de la
république avec qui j'entretiens une
relation amicale tout le monde le sait
donc cette intrusion brutale dans sur la
scène politique biarrote du ministre de
l'agriculture effectivement est assez
insolite parmi les autres candidats
même son cloche pour maïder arostéguy
conseillère municipale et candidate l
air les biarrots ne seront pas du ce
qu'on entend aujourd'hui c'est que le
parachutage même si c'est une expression
un peu particulière le parachutage n'ai
pas apprécié ses candidats n'ont pas
d'enracinement n'ont pas véritablement
d'expérience si ce n'est une expérience
de villégiature et ça aujourd'hui semble
que les citoyens le rejette
ce seront les urnes qui le diront bien
sûr la cité basque vient s'ajouter à la
liste de sujets de colère de françois
bayrou contre lrm dans le cadre des
municipales le maire de pau patron des
centristes alliés du gouvernement
n'accepte pas la candidature du ministre
de l'agriculture et de sa liste
concurrente à celle du maire modem
sortant ce mercredi edouard philippe a
déclaré qu'il n'était pas envisageable
que deux membres du gouvernement
puissent être candidats l'un contre
l'autre durablement
pourtant c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui
[Musique]